all right this is gut grinder um there
we go we got the soft people are being
attacked by something called the gut
grinder that's eating their gold so they
cover it with a cup but then they take
it out of the cup and they admit this
was kind of a bad idea because then pick
up kinder eat the gold again and
everyone thinks it's Jake because and
this thing apparently looks like Jake
and it's huge and Jake is so drawn in by
this that he actually thinks he might be
the gut grinder but he can't be because
Finn watches him when he sleeps but when
does Finn sleep justice never sleeps yes
I was better than any Batman out there I
was disturbed by both those not the fact
that he takes pictures three of them I
was very disturbed by um that's right
the funniest line but it's also like
really creepy it's the first time Finn's
like and they draw me a lot weird ways
that's like oh whatever a little boy fun
it's like no that was creepy yeah and
the ways eyes get really big like you
know I watch you when you sleep so okay
so they go and Jake turns himself in
thinking he's the grinder and then Finn
lures out the real gut grinder which is
really the Sharpie mayor's wife who just
wants gold so she can buy things and
dressed up like Jake because she thinks
Jake is hot now my question with that is
does that technically make her a
transvestite because she's dressing like
a man because she finds it hot well I
don't think it's transvestite I think
it's more along the lines of like
cosplay that's more the way I look at it
it's more cosplay because she kind of
wants to be Jake in a sense by stressing
as the other genders so but only briefly
just to steal gold kind of like weirdos
that go to comes and dress like you
except I technically steal their gold
because I saw merchandise well that's
not stealing that's more well if they
don't like the product it's kind of
stealing but they buy it so yeah
so come to my cons they're coming up
soon uh 1 December he's gonna be a 1
December to go see force viewing also
what's that dress again first viewing
dot-com yeah go to youtube and see my
first video it's called the drudge ins
dungeon I review Ghoulies also got a
website I got the glasses calm you might
have heard of it
what's that so what do you think is
episode actually this is one of the few
episodes I was not a fan of you know I
was just about to say the same thing I
think I thought this was actually kind
of a tall one
and considering it's the season finale
and yes you people may sit there and go
that's not the proper order or whatever
that's what it is on the DVD and that's
where I see it almost all the time it's
kind of a letdown as a season finale I
mean it's well I think the thing about
at the very least this first season is
it doesn't seem like it's going in any
particular order like some things do
come back as some characters come back
but it's not it's not like it's
essential you see this first episode in
order to understand these other ones I
mean they explained it pretty well if
you're not caught off by me even if you
don't know who the Ice King is it's like
they kind of set up in each episode you
get to just pretty fast um you know
there's there's never a less time on
adventure time you know sort of thing
it's not needed yeah so I doubt in this
season at least they were going for
something like that like hey we got a
really leave them on something strong
for the season finale my guess is they
probably just picked and choose which
one you know to do you know just like
okay maybe this one end uh maybe this
you know right hell they probably picked
the least entertaining one and on
because it's like well they've seen the
rest and I mean his hero would have been
a great one to end on and that's just a
really top-notch episode and like this
one was just kind of like it's kind of
boring and kind of basic like it follows
a really relatively simple plot mmm it's
not as bizarre and random as every other
episode pretty much in this season yeah
that's what I was also noticing is that
like you know boy that really was sort
of like this when the other ones would
get so random they would be so
constantly random and just so constantly
crazy and I think that
just maybe that's why it felt a little
dull cuz it's like you know it just sort
of day like you said it's a
straightforward story and I miss her
that craziness is not knowing where it's
going though I thought maybe he was
gonna sleepwalk but I mean I I guess I
couldn't predict exactly what the ending
was but yeah just not not as much
randomness now as much craziness so so
didn't do too much for me um hold except
the I watch you when you sleep why like
that that was a creepy but also funny
line well I do like when they're running
up to the gut grinder to like cut him
open cut open his stomach ya know and
then when the answer cut him I'm like oh
my god that's like oh it's a costume
okay but I did sir do like a double take
like holy crap like they did that on a
kitchen it's like but yeah obviously
it's just clawed oh yeah
but yeah trapping there's any other like
major stuff with this one I'm a I can't
even get too much to say about it I'm
like the old guy who's in prison just
cuz he likes the grubs and he tastes a
little grub in tustin his mouth and you
see the little guy just like I get the
one other thing I'll say is that their
idea a up a little bit just at the
design when Jake gets his feet the size
of fins but he doesn't change anything
else I thought that was kind of cool
actors very self propelled the more I
think about like the giant animals that
so I have like the really good legs so I
thought that was kind of funny I like
when the bag ripped open
when Finn's backpack opened up and
there's underwear and I like an eyeball
yeah just random things in the viola the
all-powerful filled life and so one
other thing I'll come a comment on is
when Jake thinks he's the grinder and
he's trying to you know going all I
could think of was failing whenever he
does is like his yelling voice like in
our
I really do and I don't know if it's
just me well watch the episode if you
haven't go just tell me if that's just
me or not we're gonna see that it ever
again the same way so it's it now
everyone with two inches episode even
though it's like probably not popular so
I do love when Jake runs up and grabs
Finn from under the gut grinder and just
hugs yeah yeah there's a couple like a
little less I mean it's not like awful
area thing any is that like oh my god
what an insult I mean it's not that all
but yeah just sort of you just sort of
mediocre so out of all my thought of all
the episode so far that I've seen it's
one of my least liked though yeah so
it's and it doesn't me it's horrible it
didn't mean it was definitely one where
else sort of becoming aware of the time
like you know
okay let's um what the next one's about
yeah I think so but yeah wasn't paying
for anything so um yeah that is any
other parting words dougie why did you
eat my fries your fries
you go watch my wife sleep aren't you he
says I don't already she left me in the
house this isn't funny don't laugh or
that no it's really funny because when
you sleep you have no idea what goes on
you think you're famous just cuz your
videos no you have to see how many
pictures are um hi